[Music]
that's where it lives right up there
and what does that say i do
i do clap away
clap away you hand clappers happy
glorious hump day america shout out to
quasimodo and puppies in heat
so who wants to have fun at the media's
expense
roll the nexio
and now the gut felt show presents you
can't fix the media you can only let it
die because they are beyond help and
suck harder than a million vacuum
cleaners powered by a zillion black
holes
and this claim is backed by science
so remember when virginia governor glenn
youngkin eased restrictions on masked
mandates the media mocked and condemned
him
like the romans did jesus
glenn young can campaign as if he were
an ordinary suburban fleece-wearing dad
with moderate and inoffensive views
younkin did exactly what a republican
does when they get into power let's look
at what's going on let's move this state
back 50 years virginia governor and
trump in training glenn younkin covent
politics
makes a lot of republican governors
stupid but now that other democrat
governors are doing the same thing
magically the media changes their tune
quicker than a jukebox on meth
more signs the country is pushing to get
back to normal new jersey delaware
connecticut oregon and california all
moved to relax their mass mandates these
are all states led by democrats and
wants hard hit covet zones and they seem
to be decisions driven by science not
politics well look
the facts are great we're headed in the
right direction as i think we hoped we
would be the responsibility should shift
from a government mandate imposed from
the state or the local district of the
school rather it should shift to an
individual responsibility by the family
it's official you can now add these
goobers to the list of other
invertebrates like jellyfish slugs
snails and tapeworms because since
things have changed and the dems are
doing what yunkan already did the
mockery stops now to be fair you say
they followed the science but why be
fair when they really followed the
political silence science just days ago
when yunkan suffered a legal setback
over ending mass mandates dems were
dunking on him like brian stelter on a
crawler
but now they're voting on legislation
that copies him they're like the dumb
kids copying the answers off the smart
kids tests
so you'd think in the media's coverage
they'd credit yunkan for being bravely
ahead of the game
but you got a better chance of pelosi
admitting her face is 85 modeling clay
because admitting their hypocrites ain't
in their dna i doubt they even know what
that word means
now while it's great to change your mind
based on data you'd think they would
think ahead about that possibility
before mocking the dude who made that
right call first but no they're
obviously two-faced fair-weather liars
jumping on the bandwagon this is not
amnesia it's arrogance for they believe
they can get away with it
i'd call them flip phonies pretty clever
eh i came up with it this morning
after putting mescaline in my count
chocula
in one instant they'll defund actual
rioters then the next brand peaceful
protesters as insurrectionists they'll
claim the canadian truckers are violent
radicals without evidence but then
ignore the antifa militant who plowed
his jeep patriot of all things into the
convoy protests and another they'll
defend to fund the police then claim
they never did and when homeless men
start beating women with baseball bats
in the unpoliced streets of seattle they
hide their anti-cop bias like it's an
ugly baby
[Laughter]
they question the validity of an
election in 2016 and then call anyone
else a traitor if they do the same thing
four years later so rather than analyze
their own rush to judgment they just run
away from the crime scene like smashing
grabbers from kay jewelers
maybe it's how they're able to sleep at
night well that and hanging upside down
but it all stems from one insecurity
they can't admit they're wrong it's
quite the contrast when you see the
podcast world exploding or successes
like this little weird show that comes
on at 11 p.m what do they all have in
common other than most of us can't pass
a drug test
we all admit that we're wrong i try to
do it a few times a week though it's
hard when you're almost always right but
every now and then i have to take off my
cape
back in 2016 i was wrong on trump and
initially i was wrong on covington i was
wrong to take hair advice from killmeade
and it was wrong taking the under on how
long jesse's show would last
finally i was wrong on canada turns out
they do have indoor plumbing
anyway being able to admit you're wrong
is like having opposable thumbs or no
tail it's a sign you've evolved but
being resistant to it means you're just
like the dying legacy media which can
never admit they're wrong at all because
maybe they're wrong so much
they do four hours of news then have to
do four hours of undoing their news
but maybe they're coming around
under jill biden's white house
or whoever is responsible for changing
joe's batteries and then steering him
towards the podium the department of
homeland security just issued a
heightened terrorism alert due to get
this the
proliferation
of false or misleading narratives which
so discord or undermine public trust in
u.s government institutions they also
cite conspiracy theories introduced and
or amplified by foreign and domestic
threats
this advisory much like cats house
arrest
remains in effect until june 7th
but this warning's big news the dhs
finally got around to watching cnn and
msnbc because it's the legacy media
churning out the false and misleading
narratives that so discord they peddled
the russian collusion hoax they uh that
which undermined our elections they lied
about kyle rittenhouse and then a
terrorist who ran over six people at a
christmas parade they portrayed all
police as violent rogues causing a
ferguson effect that led to the crime
wave
and they denied the lab leak they
embraced every hate crime hoax they
could find they pushed defunding the
police and no cash bail they even called
parents terrorists
oh wait that one was the government
it's going to be funny when they have to
kick down their own doors at dawn and
arrest themselves
maybe they should put up that fence
around the capitol again and just put a
padlock on it
anyway it's good to see the president
and his administration coming around to
seeing the destructive nature of a
vindictive media
i bet it's sure going to be hard to slap
the cuffs on your best friends
but i could be wrong i probably am it's
not hard but at least i'll admit it
let's welcome
tonight's guest she's like a jailhouse
lawyer always appealing co-host of
outnumbered emily compagno
yeah says some guy
his comedy shows bring down the house
when the club is demolished due to low
ticket sales
writer and comedian joe devito
the early bird catches the worm is her
excuse for mourning tequila fox news
contributor cat tim
and finally he showers in niagara falls
my massive sidekick and the nwa's world
television champion tyrus
emily good to see you as always glad you
could make it me too yeah do you
remember
the last time you were wrong on a topic
and would you care to explain it it
might make you feel better
i was thinking about this for a while
and i think the times that i was wrong
were when i just read headlines right
excellent point and so you brought up
kyle rittenhouse earlier and when that
when that situation started unfolding
before i looked into it before i read
about it um i thought that you know i
made the assumption that the headlines
were correct and that it was a vastly
different situation than it really was
and it actually took in-depth research
to determine that the people who died
were not a certain type of group that
they were portrayed as that he was not a
certain type of group that he was
portrayed as right it was it was just a
completely different situation i think
what um what i see is different here
than those the mainstream media is in
part that i mean we're thoughtful
there's not group think you say what you
think at that time and that's why later
on you can say you know what i was wrong
because now i know differently or now
i've changed my mind you know what i've
changed my mind that's okay too no one
in the mainstream media is doing so
because they're saying they're talking
points and they have their group think
collectively that they have to do and if
i can just make one quick point too
about the mask wearing and how everyone
points to like a higher authority that
is infallible so everyone points to the
cdc right that you have to wear masks
you have to mask your kids virginia
passes a state law that says we will
rely on the cdc guidance for everything
that we have to do the school board and
this is why we're arresting people right
and left for breaking laws basically
right but that same cdc says that 51 of
kids there's been a 51 increase in
suicide that same cdc says that these
kids are declining in mental health and
in peer group social social status and
sociality uh by double digits right now
they are saying that our kids are dying
on the inside so if they're perfectly
infallible in this and that's what we
rely on in laws says mainstream media
says state law then why can't the other
things they say be correct also it's
only with covet it's only in these
certain instances that these authorities
are correct
excellent points emily you get a passing
grade yes
uh joe how you doing good great beard
coming along growing in yes excellent
excellent good good good
okay
yeah gonna shave off the mustache and
pull a tyrus no i don't think that works
okay first of all you know why i don't
grow a mustache my mustache hair is
racist
yes he's got white you have white hair
yeah yeah my grandfather i want to see
that it's blonde yes
doesn't get along with the
rest the vision is rough on my face yes
uh joe do you uh remember the last time
you said something that you now think
you were wrong yes uh i used to spend a
lot of time making fun of canada
and if this whole system is brought down
by angry canadian truckers i'm going to
laugh my ass off right i know because
who would have thought who would have
thought and and when i saw them starting
to do the the protests up there i
thought well it's a canadian thing so as
a some of the united states i don't
really have to pay attention right but
i've been watching them and it just is
so funny how canadian it is too and to
see such canadian pride yes that they're
what's more canadian than honking yes
it's the geese do it the truckers do it
they're really they're really enjoying
the canadian-ness of it and to see the
way that the media is attacking them and
their own prime minister right he's
accused they're nazis they're
transphobic they're racist he's going
down this long list and when you see
them they've set up saunas and bouncy
houses i know bouncy castles yes yes but
i want to point out you can't spell
honky without honk this is true this is
true yeah it's pretty amazing but you're
right
people are talk people are talking about
like terrorists while you're looking up
at tv and there's you're looking on tv
and there's a little baby in a baby
carriage and another lady holding a baby
and it's like what who brings who brings
babies to a terrorist activity well well
hamas
yes yes uh care to admit uh well i've
i'm
wrong a lot um at least that's what she
tells me but um
i'd probably say the biggest thing i was
wrong about was busgate and i remember i
came on the show and i was like that's
it it's over like trump's done oh that
was wrong with that too yeah i was bus
it was a rap you know and uh yes and
more recently the biggest one is that i
was completely wrong about president
biden i was you know defending saying
he's going to be a moderate yeah he's
going to be that tough on crime guy and
he's not gonna fold any of this he's
just being nice to be elected and uh
my bad america
i remember the bus thing i was you know
what i did when we did the five i
entered my segment with the song it's
over by boss gags and i was just
laughing the whole time yeah we talked
about on this before the show after the
show at the bar yeah i was like well
we're gonna have four years of hillary
here
totally wrong cat do you remember
anything in your past i know it's hard
to remember
because i'm black out drunk all the time
i like it when she's gonna whoop your
ass
yeah i don't know i mean like i'm not
proven wrong a lot because i'm
libertarian and so we never get elected
so we never have a chance to be proven
wrong that is true but we don't win i
would say
i was definitely wrong about i thought
there was no way trump would win in
2016. no way
i was wrong i did not think that i would
get so much coveted
i don't go anywhere and i got so much
coverage
i got coveted i thought after i got two
vaccine shots and the one colvin that
there's no way i'd get coveted again
that same year but i sure did hey that
and you just won the segment because
i've had it three times so much i've had
the three boosters and all the stuff so
i'm looking forward to the fourth i'm
like planning a party for it you're like
literally a bug lamp covey loves me
i've had all three versions it's like i
should get like a badge of participation
oh my god must be cat's obesity
i never really got sick but i kept
getting you know testing positive but i
was always like called the beginning i
remember i was like covered no big deal
no big deal so it hurt me yeah
it did
and i get you you [ __ ] the good news is
after a couple days
you know after a couple days it left you
because i was like fine but excited to
stay home like i had to just be by my i
don't do well alone and oh man well that
was educational hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else